fourth of July is just around the corner
and there's this public service
announcement from the US Consumer
Product Safety Commission and this video
is supposed to make you not want to use
fireworks but everyone that's watching
it it just makes them want to do
fireworks is awesome he is on fire
expand in every state right now or did
just California we can't have any fun
it'd be great if chintz search history
popped up and it's just like all like
Skype aid [ __ ] videos bodies it's
there's only mastery only masters it
bans the sale of it and use of it and
then Tuesdays Illinois and Vermont
permit the sale and used only wire or
woodstick sparklers and other novelties
sorry I guess we're the only state that
says we can't have them well we cannot
just apply on we just can't do it in
certain cities I'll tell you this right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue
okay what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
Oh